[Music]
on this wednesday night the russian
onslaught on major ukrainian cities
the relentless shelling devastating
civilians as peace talks between russia
and ukraine show some signs of progress
plus fleeing war the ukrainian refugees
now calling canada home here finally i
can say that i'm safe
soaring inflation as canada's inflation
rate continues to rise where will you
feel it the most
also tonight easing covet 19 travel
restrictions we can't keep testing
ourselves cool our life why getting into
canada is about to get a whole lot
easier and virtual medics the canadian
doctors helping train their ukrainian
counterparts to treat victims of war
[Music]
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight tracy tong
good evening and thank you for joining
us some chilling words coming from
president vladimir putin in this third
week of russia's war on ukraine putin is
accusing the west of trying to divide
russia and provoke civil confrontation
saying in russian quote i am convinced
that this natural and necessary
self-cleansing of society will only
strengthen our country our solidarity
cohesion and readiness to meet any
challenge
this comes on the same day ukrainian
president vladimir zelinsky delivered a
speech to u.s congress where he again
pushed for a nato enforced no-fly zone a
move the west is still refusing to make
though the czech prime minister who met
zielinski in kiev yesterday is throwing
his support behind supplying ukraine
with more weapons
he says a no-fly zone is not realistic
but the ukrainians can create a certain
no-fly zone themselves if they have
enough military equipment and
anti-aircraft missiles
while ukraine rallies for more
international support the situation on
the ground is getting increasingly worse
crystal commancing reports and a warning
some of the images are disturbing
the kremlin continues to deny russian
forces are attacking civilian locations
in ukraine but in chernihiv people were
lined up early in the morning looking to
get bread to eat when the missile hit
ukrainian officials say at least 10
people were killed i am in front of the
residential building maria abdieva has
been documenting the destruction that's
leveling her home city of harkief she
says civilians in her community have
also been killed
just trying to get food and supplies
it's like on the go in a constant
situation of of
threatening the civilian population and
i think that is one of the goals to
to terrorize the civilians
from the north to the south anguish
lingers on the faces of so many at this
morgue in mikolaiv people come looking
hoping to not find their loved ones
some of those killed were professional
soldiers but many others were mothers
fathers and young people just starting
their lives who picked up arms to defend
their country
he was so friendly he had a lot of
friends and got on well with everyone
his 37 year old son was killed in action
it's as if a big bag fell on me he says
everything was good everything was
beautiful
in russia this war is not called a war
but a special occupation and while
ukrainian forces continue to hold back
russian fighters in many cities
ukrainians are paying with their lives a
convoy of vehicles leaving the besieged
southern city of mariupol was hit
wednesday five people were reportedly
wounded including a child
it's believed close to 100 children have
been killed in 21 days of fighting
kiev has been kept from falling into
russian control for now for weeks
soldiers have been on the outskirts but
no ground advance has taken place
airstrikes however are ongoing
the curfew in the capital will be in
place again tonight the mayor of kiev
says it is just too dangerous to be
outside given the relentless
bombardments tracy
and crystal despite the situation on the
ground ukraine's president says this
latest round of peace talks with russia
is sounding quote more realistic what
does that mean after three consecutive
days of negotiations
yeah well we should highlight the fact
that three consecutive days that's the
first time that that has happened and
both sides are using some positive
language language specifically around
the issue of ukraine's neutrality
however ukrainians that i have spoken
with say it was vladimir putin who
started this war and it is only putin
who can end it and they're not convinced
that he would honor a peace deal should
one be brokered tracy
crystal gomezing in london thank you
with the war intensifying the chief
prosecutor of the international criminal
court says there will be zero tolerance
for any crimes against children
we need to get to the truth and that
will be the foundation of deciding if
crimes are committed and if so who is
responsible and we take it step by step
but we need to act with some urgency and
with some focus
the icc has begun a formal investigation
into possible war crimes and crimes
against humanity in ukraine
prosecutors say they have already
collected more than 300 witness
statements hundreds of civilians are
dead and more than three million people
have fled the country since the invasion
began nearly three weeks ago
and the un's top court for disputes
between states has ordered russia to
stop its invasion of ukraine immediately
the international court of justice says
it's profoundly concerned by president
vladimir putin's use of force and sees
no evidence to support any of his
justifications including trying to
prevent a genocide in eastern ukraine
ukrainian president zielenski also
disputes those grounds for the invasion
and today he delivered another powerful
speech this time to members of the u.s
congress zielinski included a video
produced by the ukrainian government
showing the toll the war is taking on
his country and he evoked memories of
the attacks on september 11th and pearl
harbor
heather urix west reports on the
response to his plea for a no-fly zone
or at least fighter jets
kiev
odessa against a somber soundtrack the
ukrainian president presented this video
to u.s lawmakers wednesday showing
ukraine first as it was a short time ago
before
all of this
i am addressing
the president biden
you are the leader
of the nation
i wish you
to be the leader of the world russia has
turned the ukrainian sky into a source
of death president vladimir zelinsky
said in ukrainian as he again asked the
u.s to support a no-fly zone over his
country if not airplanes to protect the
skies
calling russian president vladimir putin
a war criminal u.s president joe biden
responded with a pledge to send ukraine
a mammoth military aid package an
additional 800 million dollars in
assistance
that brings the total of new u.s
security assistance to ukraine to one
billion dollars just this week
the u.s stopped short of sending polish
mig fighter jets but they are delivering
weapons to defend both land and sky
including drones and anti-aircraft
systems this will allow them to keep the
struggle going and do it at a time when
the russians are drawing down their
stocks i am literally tired of crying a
short distance from capitol hill
ukrainian cafe owner anastasia darun
fights back tears her mother and
grandmother will soon arrive in
washington from kiev where her father
and so many other family members remain
he said don't tell mom that i'm crying
because he didn't want to upset her
but he said that he's a little bit
scared
and i never seen my dad being scared her
wish echoing that of so many others that
somehow soon all this bloodshed will end
heather urex west global news washington
some ukrainians fleeing war are headed
to canada the feds say their new program
to expedite arrivals will accept
applications this week and as lauren
poland reports ukrainians will have to
brace for a potential backlog
finally able to sit side by side not
going to lie it feels a big big relief
like somebody touched my heart with a
palm like this
huddled close together on a porch swing
here finally i can say that i am safe
these are but two of more than three
million ukrainian refugee stories
tamila kovolchuk didn't want to leave
ukraine but after airports a hospital
and school were bombed around her her
children told her she needed to get out
after an excruciating eight-day journey
to get to her son's home in calgary
tamila still can't help but think of
home and her other son she had to leave
behind
this is the second time arena pustovic
and her daughter paulina have been
forced to flee fighting first leaving
their home near donbass to live in key
back in 2014 now calling canada home at
least for now
scenes of tearful embraces are unfolding
all across canada and soon there may be
many more a federal emergency travel
program is about to open canada's doors
wide most visa requirements will be
waived for ukrainians to stay at least
two years canadian organizations working
to welcome fleeing ukrainians say they
don't know how many are coming but
they're bracing for thousands and they
say they're ready to help make the
transition as smooth as possible
unfortunately in war nothing is seamless
and it's really devastating and it's
really difficult but
hopefully together as a community we can
at least make it a little bit less
stressful
those already here are finding comfort
in daily calls home i wanted so by them
like i wanted them to come here to see
them
and i don't know to hug them holding out
hope that day comes soon lauren pulling
global news calgary
canada's inflation rate is on the rise
again reaching more than five percent
for a second straight month inflation
rose to 5.7 percent in february the
first time it's hit that mark since 1991
31 years ago
gas prices shot up 32 percent year over
year and rent is up 4.2 percent across
the board as ann gaviola reports
consumers will continue to feel the
pinch
your hard-earned money isn't going as
far as it used to there's more in store
at the pumps the grocery aisles and
everywhere in between
batten down the hatches
my expectation is food price increases
will continue for a while yet the price
of meat one of big culprits especially
beef because of drought conditions in
western parts of canada and the us but
all of that is looking in the rearview
mirror at what already happened some
economists warn of 80s style inflation
looming putting pressure on the central
bank to raise rates spring and summer is
going to
have even higher inflation passing six
percent
is an absolute uh certainty
perhaps even pushing towards the seven
percent mark
move over kovid the crisis in ukraine is
now the top wild card when it comes to
inflation russia is one of the world's
biggest energy exporters ukraine and
russia together export a quarter of all
wheat and our major producers of corn
potatoes and barley factory in tough
sanctions on russia and countries like
egypt which depends on both countries
for wheat could see widespread food
shortages
the region also produces minerals used
in everything from cars to fertilizer
and tech devices add that to existing
supply chain challenges and you have a
recipe for much higher prices and even
more goods shortages all of this will
hit developing nations hardest and here
at home it will be felt most by
vulnerable households they're also
getting squeezed by gas prices and are
getting squeezed by
rent increases all of those
they're going to have to make some
harder choices
many of us will cut back where we can
but growing your investments is another
approach through the housing market or
stocks and sound financial planning
there are many good quality companies
that are trading very cheaply and we're
even calling them stupid cheap at this
point in that they they keep increasing
earnings every little bit helps to blunt
the erosion of your purchasing power
anne gaviola global news toronto
honda canada is investing in the
manufacturing of hybrid vehicles with
help from the federal government and
province of ontario prime minister
justin trudeau and premier doug ford
each committed 131 million dollars to
retool honda's alliston ontario facility
the upgrade will cost about 1.4 billion
dollars over six years
the prime minister says the production
of hybrid electric vehicles at the plant
will create thousands of jobs
one important travel requirement is set
to disappear
coming up how re-entering canada is
about to get easier
[Music]
a lingering covet 19 requirement for
travelers is set to disappear federal
government sources tell global news
vaccinated travelers will no longer need
proof of a negative test in order to
enter the country abigail beeman reports
on the long-awaited move
we can't keep testing ourselves whole
our lives news the pre-arrival clovid
test requirement will soon be scrapped
as welcomed by these travelers i think
it's all good just get back to normal
i'm so excited to hear that global news
has confirmed the government is set to
announce a pcr or antigen test will no
longer be required for those entering
canada by land or by air businesses
airline and travel industries have been
lobbying for the change for some time
calling it a non-science-based obstacle
for a lot of business travelers having
those pre-departure tests has been just
another barrier that's made it
more difficult for either canadians to
go travel abroad or to have people's you
know foreign customers come into canada
most medical professionals agree the
sensitivity of a rapid test is obviously
quite limited so it was more of a
symbolic thing than anything else once
you sort of move away from pcr testing
there are other rules expected to stay
in place random testing for incoming
travelers and the requirements to be
fully vaccinated and use the arrivedcan
app which makes sense for surveillance
purposes right because there will
probably unfortunately be new variants
for those who may be nervous the virus
is not gone on vacation or is still
around so i prefer to know people who
come in is
tested negative experts say the risk of
contracting covet in the air is low with
airlines continuing to request masking
for everybody on the flight and with
ensuring that people who are traveling
have vaccine certification to show that
they're fully vaccinated i think the
addition of pre-travel testing is
actually the least effective the
announcement could come as early as
thursday abigail beeman global news
ottawa
ahead the potential long-term risks for
children who catch covet 19.
more than 85 percent of canadians aged
five and older are fully vaccinated
against covert 19 but children under 5
still cannot get their shots that's a
concern for parents sending kids back to
school as indoor mask mandates ease as
jamie maraca reports new research
suggests a quarter of kids who get
infected develop long covet
ten-year-old matthew kirkpatrick spent
the summer gaining independence but a
bout of covid19 at the start of the
school year has stripped it all away the
doctors were saying
nothing alone no showering alone you
know if he was trying to learn to cook
no cooking alone
you know no
no physical activities nancy kirkpatrick
says the life-limiting advice came after
her son collapsed on his way home from
school there's this alleyway near my
house and
i passed out and
then i just woke up he had two more
severe blackouts
one was at school where he just fell out
of his desk matthew's post-coveted
symptoms also included chest pain and
dizziness a cardiologist diagnosed him
with tachycardia a condition where the
heartbeat races more than 100 times per
minute a new large-scale pre-print study
looked at more than 80 thousand children
with covid while cardiorespiratory
post-covet symptoms were more rare it
found one in four kids who had the virus
developed some form of long covid the
most common symptoms that were seen were
mood symptoms sleep disturbances and
fatigue and these can be sort of
really common symptoms after anybody
recovers from a viral illness but
it is concerning that we saw those
symptoms continue for at least a month
after somebody had covered claire
hastie's 13 year old twins got coveted
two years ago they've been dealing with
lingering fatigue gastrointestinal
issues and extreme joint pain ever since
it's heartbreaking all of the relapses
and symptoms have really made it
difficult there are a few answers
treatment can be limited and prevention
vaccination isn't available to everyone
matthew kirkpatrick wasn't eligible for
a vaccine when he caught covet in
september you know i regret to this day
putting him in school until he was
vaccinated
a risk some families are still being
forced to take as they wait for an
approved vaccine for the youngest
canadians jamie morocco global news
toronto
next how canadian doctors are supporting
their ukrainian counterparts
it is difficult to confirm the true
number of people injured in russian
attacks on ukraine but the need for
frontline trauma care is dire and goes
well beyond what many doctors are
accustomed to
mike delay looks at how some canadian
doctors are trying to help save lives in
a war zone from half a world away she
was well inflated these are skills
needed on the front lines in ukraine
being taught in how to videos by doctors
at mcgill university using mannequins
they go through trauma procedures step
by step chest tube insertions
cricothyroidotomies and other urgent
medical acts or complex facial
structures before they're translated
into ukrainian
complicated surgeries for less than
ideal situations
the process of simplifying things can be
is very challenging uh it needs to be
more elegant it needs to be more on
point
ukraine has surgeons but like most
countries they don't have enough
throughout the country and on the front
lines to serve all those in need right
now during a bloody war so the mcgill
doctor has targeted medical
professionals medics and doctors who can
help save lives with a bit of rapid
refresher training it's something very
personal to dr nadia demko who has
family in ukraine i think it's actually
the driving force for me is is knowing
how how much they're being affected by
it dr tarak lubani knows from personal
experience how critical urgent cares and
supplies can be
he was working in the gaza strip as a
medic in 2018 when he was shot in both
legs there weren't enough tourniquets to
go around so he had to treat and sew up
his own wounds
i was very lucky i was
i was shot in areas that don't bleed
very much so i lost blood i lost
probably half a liter now he works with
a group called glia which is raising
money to 3d print as many tourniquets as
they can they can't get them printed in
ukraine they'll assemble and ship them
from elsewhere in fact we want other
people to make it we just want to make
sure that they make it safely and they
make it in a way so that it's saving
lives everywhere that's what they all
swore to dedicating their careers to
saving lives even from half a world away
anything we can do to help navigate this
even the smallest degree of support is
is of such great value people on the
front lines in ukraine can certainly use
the help mike drolite global news
toronto
and that is global national for this
wednesday music has emerged as a
powerful symbol of resistance in ukraine
we want to leave you tonight with a
moment of peace in the darkest of times
[Music]
this pianist sat down to play her grand
piano one last time before fleeing her
bombed out family home as she performs
in etude by chopin the camera pans
around the piles of debris she says it
wasn't a sad moment the music helped her
remember all the good times in the house
thank you so much for watching have a
good night
[Music]
you